presumably you welcome the seven billion
pounds worth of investment which
incidentally is going to benefit uh your
uh constituency of lee in leeds
well let's hope so but what we see from
this government is lots of announcements
and much less delivery
northern powerhouse rail that would
benefit leeds and bradford and
manchester and other towns and cities
across yorkshire was first announced
seven years ago it's been announced 60
times since then and there's still not a
single spade in the ground
or train on the rails
it's not good enough and the government
are going to make more announcements
this week
but we're sick of in the north having
announcements without the delivery on
the ground and we want to see
concrete action to match the rhetoric of
this government that's really important
for all of us in the north of england
but your your labor colleagues uh tracy
braven and andy burnham have been rather
positive about this announcement um in
fact uh andy burnham said yesterday
uh this is not a day for negativity um
aren't you being a bit mean
well of course new money is welcome but
as i say trevor it's got to be backed up
with actual action and northern
powerhouse rail the eastern leg of hs2
the dismal state that many of our bus
services in with cuts over the last few
years and higher fares all of those
things need addressing and it's it's of
course welcome always to have more
investment
but if that investment isn't backed up
with actual delivery
it's really not worth the paper it's
written on and that is the frustration
in many towns and cities across the
north of england the while big ground
projects get delivered elsewhere in the
country they're few and far between in
our towns and cities and northern
powerhouse rail i think is the best
example
of a huge gaping chasm now between the
rhetoric of the government and the
actual delivery for people on the ground
okay well look would you give a tick at
least to the 500 million for early years
education which is a thing i know from
your parliamentary career that you care
about quite a lot
i just would say to the chancellor have
you ever heard of sure start
because that is what your governments
over the last 11 years have cut and it's
all well and good saying we're going to
invest in these family parks
but thousands of children centres and
shore start centers
that were proud features of our
communities especially some of our
poorest communities
have long gone
and tessa jowl and harriet harmon and of
vet cooper and others in previous labour
governments who made those happen
i think there's a real feeling that if
you hadn't have taken all that away
imagine what difference it could have
made to the lives of young people and to
their parents and this pale imitation
which doesn't even take us back to where
we were in 2010
i think is an insult to all those people
who created investment
and made sure start happen in the first
place and it was such a proud
achievement of the last labour
government
and it really was an act of criminality
to rip that all up
only to now 11 years later create a pale
imitation of it
i am frequently uh saying to you and
your colleagues um what would you do and
complaining that you don't give me an
answer but in fact this morning you've
already said that um
you would cut vat
on domestic energy supplies
at a cost you estimate of a billion
pounds um i think that's interesting
who's going to tell andy burnham that
if you were chancellor he wouldn't be
getting the transport um improvements
which coincidentally cost about a
billion pounds because you want to spend
it uh on uh energy
well no one would have to say that sir
andy burnham i would say to andy burnham
we'll invest in the transport in greater
manchester and across the north of
england and give you the powers
to do that because too many decisions
are still made in whitehall and
westminster and not in the towns and
cities and regions of our country and we
want to devolve more powers to andy to
tracy to dan jarvis and to our other
great metro mayors around the country
we've been clear about how we would pay
for this cut in vit but let me just say
why it's so important but people have
been facing now a tough winter with the
prices of everything going up not least
our gas and electricity bills and
everybody is feeling the pinch
when we pay our gas and electricity
bills each month five percent of that
bill goes directly to the tax man
and what labour are saying
is let's reduce that rate of vat on gas
and electricity bills from five percent
to zero percent for six months to get us
through this winter period
and that would be an immediate and
automatic reduction
to the bills of every single family and
pensioner across our country
and we would pay for that by using
the vat receipts that have come in
higher than forecast higher than
forecast by over two billion pounds over
the last few months not least because
prices are so much higher than they were
forecast let's use that additional
revenue that has flowed into the
treasury these last few months
to make that important reduction in vat
on gas and electricity bills to ease
that pressure on people who are
struggling right now with the rising
cost of living at the same time that
taxes are going up
but i suspect that that um that extra
money has already been allocated
elsewhere and the chancellor's plan so
um if you're not going to
find it from
andy's money or tracy braeburn's 830
million or the 830 million for the fe
skills budget or t levels
where is this actually going to be or is
this the magic money tree turning up
again
trevor you're asking me what labour
would do if it was our budget on
wednesday and our priority would be
easing the cost of living price um
crisis helping businesses who have had a
torrid 18 months and addressing some of
the long-term challenges that we face
with climate crisis but also our plans
to buy make and sell more in britain and
if it was our budget on wednesday we
would be using those additional vot
receipts to cut v80 on gas and
electricity bills because we know what a
difficult time so many families and also
pensioners are facing whatever
with worries about rising prices and
worries about rising gas and electricity
bills and that is labor's priority and
that is what labour would do
i'm sorry to interrupt you chancellor
but you last time you were on you told
me that um
you would abolish business rates at a
stroke that will cost 25 billion pounds
uh okay you might be able to find a
little bit of underspending and so on
but it's not going to count to 25
billion pounds you haven't got the money
on business rates what we've said is
that next year instead of increasing
business rates like this government plan
to do we would freeze business rates for
all and we would extend the small
business rates relief and we would pay
for that by increasing the digital
services tax on firms who have done well
these latin a last 18 months as people's
spending patterns have changed that
would bring in just over 2 billion
pounds and that would enable us to
freeze rates and extend smaller business
rates relief but we know these problems
run deeper than
just some tinkering around the edges in
one year only and that's why labour have
committed to abolish business rates and
replace it with a fairer form of
business property taxation
what do i mean by that
first of all i mean if you wouldn't mind
small businesses
the high street businesses and small
businesses shouldn't have to bear such a
disproportionate burden of business
rates
out of town warehouses for example are
attacked at a much lower rate than high
street businesses but we've also got a
situation okay where some of our big
digital companies are not paying
corporation tax in this country the
global minimum rate of corporation tax
the receipts from that should ease the
burden of business rates on high street
and small businesses that would be
favors priorities